gang real quick before we get this
episode started summer is going into
full swing and so is the
are you garbage keep it moving 20 21
tour oh yeah we're gonna be coming to a
town near you
for a little bit of stand up and we're
gonna be answering your
garbage questions kippy tell them what
they need to know july 14th columbus
funny bone
july 15 cleveland hilarities august 11th
rhode island comedy connection august
12th left boston those tickets are
cooking that's going to sell out
get those tickets then august 25th we're
at new brunswick stress factory and then
august 26th we're at magooby's joke
house in timonium
maryland right outside of baltimore i
like it gang get some ticks
come out and see it's gonna be a
fantastic fun time a mix of stand-up
comedy in the ayg game
come out and hang with uncle hank and
your aunt kippy
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals
or absolute trash now
here are your hosts kevin ryan and
h foley hey everybody out there
and welcome back to everybody i love
that
favorite new podcast this is ru garbage
goddamn it sure is
it's a little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find out if
they grow up to be classy
or if they're just a big old piece of
trash
i'm your host age foley coming at you on
a beautiful day we're down here at
antootie's basement
something i have to discuss with you
what's that by chance
sure i had two scratch-offs on the
kitchen table upstairs uh-huh did you
take them i didn't you're sure i know
yeah of course
great tony's back gambling again
my co-host is coming at you from right
next to me that really had legs
[Laughter]
he's the ceo of gary garb which he's my
boss god damn it show this bozo a little
respect willie yeah he's got a big
forehead but he's a good kid
put the whole thing together give it up
for kevin james ryan
hey gang happy to be here thank you i
say that with all due respect right
jesus christ this [ __ ] paycheck do i
know it is
oh believe me i know patty we're eating
good this weekend baby
uh fried bologna for everybody uh guys
thanks for tuning in as always please
make sure you rate review subscribe on
itunes full video available on youtube
and as you know those numbers are
true the roof true the [ __ ] roof yes
sir and let me tell you about
some this is through the roof through
the [ __ ] stratosphere into another
galaxy talking about the patreon on
patreon.com talk to me in the first
class laughs
guys check it out patreon.com you get
bonus episodes of ayg
you get episodes of hard feelings which
is you know uh now everybody's new new
favorite podcast
the ten day if you're signing up sign up
for the 10 level that's what you're
that's what you got to do
savings for the whole family uh and then
we uh with the top tier we do live
streams where we play ayg with you guys
every month it's a good [ __ ] time get
involved
also real quick shows coming out july
14th and july 15th we're going to be in
ohio
columbus funny bone and hilarity
cleveland hilarity's in cleveland get
those [ __ ] tickets because they are
moving they're cooking believe it or not
they're [ __ ] moving and if you want
to come see us in boston
do yourself a favor that's going to go
soon get get the
the the the prepaid whatever it is the
spot on your check
whatever you gotta do to get the cash
get it and make a move now yeah because
they ain't gonna like it that's not
cause that's gonna go very soon and how
about a nice shout out to our producer
extraordinaire he is the magic man
t-bone mcmuffin
it's toby mcmullen d-bone what's up
dudes good to see you buddy great job on
the [ __ ]
ac videos [ __ ] killing it thanks
kid's been working his balls off oh yeah
on the patreon we post longer versions
of the live shows we post like you know
eight to ten minute chunks of the live
shows on patreon so check that out
yeah can you guys do me a favor get in
there and do the dishes cause i've been
in the kitchen cooking
i made a hot meal for all these gang we
could not
be more excited to have our incredibly
incredibly special guest
here with us today she's back with us
you loved her so much you've all been
asking when she coming back once you're
coming back when she's coming back
we got her here right now it was the
first episode in tutti's first episode
in today's and now here we are we're
about a month away from her wedding
she's the bride to be daddy's little
angel getting married
don't tell anyone
give it up for casey balsham everybody
thanks for having me back i'm so proud
of you guys like it's so funny like you
know you do
i'm just so excited to hear my friends
like that they're going to ohio and bot
like it just but it feels like real [ __ ]
you know like i
always do podcasts and i was like i'm
never going to go to [ __ ] ohio that's
not you know
i love you you're really doing it really
proud
thank thank you so much for coming in
and sitting with us this is a company
episode
we're going to be answering some patreon
questions but we thought since we had
you here
you got the wedding coming up i know we
wanted to talk about it's going to be
the [ __ ] social event of the season i
hope so
the front page of laugh button they're
saying
where you got to be if you weren't at
the [ __ ]
the boston slovak wedding you're not in
the business is jeffrey gordian going to
be there
yeah is he really well you'll be able to
smell them if you just you know
smell them coming from the woods no i
actually yeah most people had to submit
a tape but i let you guys know
where you were you were invited
so what clubs do you get up at regularly
yeah oh let's see
where you gotta get two recommendations
to go to this wedding yeah yeah yeah
yeah that's we're gonna find out where
we're really at the biz where where
we're sitting
sure that's so this is basically sorry
in the woods i am
we've talked about your wedding a good
amount on patreon and on the
regular episodes because this is a good
thing oh yeah that's right we've been
saying that we have this wedding coming
up this is the wedding it's mine because
now we have you know
i went and bought a suit yesterday i
bought a brand new suit yesterday
which we'll get into by the way [ __ ]
bamboozled over there bonobos never be
as much
upside down in a three-button euro cut i
mean if it's if it's fun to say there's
no way that it's serious yeah
you can't get anything serious from
bonobos
where'd you pick this merchandise up at
it's getting shipped to me well whatever
we'll get into it i don't think
somebody's buying suits off amazon i'm
going to lose it
i've got to be honest with you i was
furious at the whole transaction
but we've talked about what we're going
to wear now that we have a little bit of
cash we want to look good we want to
show off
i love it it's the new money we want to
we want to represent ourselves
as new you know not the bozos we once
were
i got a sweet bryce harper jersey
as long as you guys don't show up in
jeans i'm like terrified that that scopo
is going to show up in like a [ __ ]
message
he's got a baseball bat on his shoulder
yeah but there there always is
i mean there's always one guy at a
wedding
maybe not jeans but there's always the
one somebody underdressed
in khakis see khakis i would khakis
don't even cause it's the middle
it's the middle of summer it's new york
it's gonna be hot we're gonna i mean
like dockers
dockers yeah if you show up to my
wedding and cargo pants i will send you
i will tell you to take a walk on the
ground you got a whole suit of cargo
pants
it's got the pockets on the jeep yes
it's a full suit unless it's a costume
then i'm fine
but if you're just like if you just
dress shitty on purpose and like not
funny
but i'm scared like i've already had
people ask if they can wear shorts and
i've had to be like i'm not
sure i don't think i think well they do
they are selling suits like suit with
the shorts
they're like and they look nice which is
kind of if it's like
if you can pull it you have to be in
really good shape and good looking to
pull that off otherwise you're like a
fan
yeah you can't hem your pants that you
apparently have and keep your jet like
you'll look like a [ __ ] ass
or you wear like or like i sent some of
my college friends i sent them like on
amazon they've got like bright red ones
or ones that just have like piano keys
over them i'd be like this i'd be okay
with because you guys we were theater
majors and you're ridiculous
but in general i'm i i feel like i've
been telling people like
you know a nice [ __ ] like dress like a
girl like an adult dress like you've
done
this conversation yeah and kevin yelled
at me for grilling you about what to
wear because i was worried about it too
and as we've said on the podcast it's
tricky for a fat guy
because you could go out and get the
nicest suit the nicest shirt and tie
but once that jacket comes off and like
you know it's the buffet time
everything's pulled out you know you you
look like a principal
[Laughter]
mr foley you can't control these kids
you could be yelling at everybody to go
to sleep be quiet in the halls
um is that weed i smell it will be
are you worried about people
will you be upset if somebody shows up
very underdressed no i mean in all
honesty like my wedding's gonna be a
[ __ ] circus i was just
i just told you guys i was trying to buy
toys at a store like i was literally
trying to buy those yard long drinks
that they sell in vegas to like just
have on hand for fun
and you are trying you are [ __ ]
garbage no i just love vegas and i
like i told that tell me that was not
not on the list of places to get
married i told robbie i was like vegas
and he's like absolutely [ __ ] not
yeah well he's like a mild mannered
gentleman yeah he's i know
he's put together he's got some trashy
roots and stuff like that but he's
totally
subtle together you're just off you're
looking for
you know three foot long [ __ ]
drinking updates yeah
i mean for your wedding guys i ate it's
supposed to be a bribe i hate it you
want a kamikaze foundation
if that was available i [ __ ] would i
truly like
to buy the fireball wait he's from tampa
he claims tampa he's great from all over
he's grown up everywhere but he's born
in south africa
yeah and then gentlemen england lived in
gibraltar lived in [ __ ] cities these
are learned people well if he brings any
guests from tampa you better check him
for zany bars
there's a whole table of people from
tampa they are i kind of want to sit at
that table to be honest
adventure island pass holders they're
season pass holders that's what their
table is called
there is just a [ __ ] bus of tampa
people told me a little margaritaville
and cocaine yeah
i mean i'm not saying someone's gonna
have a cut off for sure
someone's gonna have a snakeskin jean
jacket oh
i don't even know if that's a thing but
if it is send me one if you're gonna get
snake skin denim yeah tampa floor is
working
yeah exactly um no i'm i'm i i yeah
i am trying to keep this as classic
because it's also expensive but in my
head i'm i've like i've like
already bought just toys and things i
have a
i have a drag queen singing at dinner
like there's just it's going to be a
[ __ ]
tiger king that's what i'm saying the
tiger king
i should have had a theme i should have
had
but i wanted to make sure that i didn't
embarrass you so i
that's why i asked you specifically
right with what i what i
wear would be okay because i'm combining
with kevin has taught me over the last
couple of months about etiquette and
stuff like that
and putting myself together well but
then i also don't want to have the
[ __ ] shirt tucked in
thinking short sleeve button down okay
untucked nice
with a nice blue suit you can't hit
short sleeve
button down untucked and with nice
because when i take the jacket when i
take the jacket
nice you're trash you're fat trash
that's what you're
untucked no tie nice i'm not doing a tie
i'm talking a nice bowling pin right
here on the lapel oh my god
you can wear a bolero tie yeah what's a
valero type a bolero tie is like one of
those like uh oh
like it's like a weighted thing i hate
those i would polo i call them
yes yes that's what that's thank you
that's it's that's it's a street name
if you're
good so you have a blue suit not yet i'm
gonna
okay and what's your suit well i have
i'm pretty good at suits okay i have a
handful of suits already
uh all dark i got a suit uh
when i got married last year i got one
made but it was
wool because it was on the winner so
it's thick i'm like yeah i need a summer
suit this is gonna be
hot i got a couple of weddings this
summer uh and i'm like
one in italy no in germany we're going
to germany like two days after your
wedding oh nice
um this guy huh zipping our
international business
i gotta go get more [ __ ] investors
because we're banking over packy
briefcase
what time's the ship leave from the
docks to get the euros
the wedding's in december
you guys are working your way across on
a lobster boat
um so we even had a naw [ __ ]
that was three different accidents to be
honest with you showing my range baby
show them my range you never know who's
watching
folks i'm available
[Laughter]
i said lobster i'm from boston
getting ready for my show you are the
type of guy to show up to a wedding in a
fake character
and like switch it up at every table
yeah no never oh what do you mean
personality wise i've never really been
at weddings where i was that anonymous
like people
anybody i've ever gotten invited
everybody knew who i was was not saying
much no of course not
that's very telling of your personality
nobody wants to be around you unless
they're related to you and you have to
be their contractor
the infamous foley is coming to the
wedding everyone's like oh my god
[ __ ] we gotta invite henry that's what
the conversation goes we were talking
off air before uh
i thought i've had some instances where
i've embarrassed myself
at my at weddings casey also admitted i
mean
similar the ones that i can remember
were were a mess
i bet because here's the thing i'm a fun
time you know me but you know when i
booze it up
i get a little i get a little question
she's a little older
well we call it tootie she's a little
bunco okay
it's broad bonkos uh so i do i do
remember one
a wedding that i went to whose wedding
was it was my friend from college
uh kristen are you going solo i went
solo
yeah so are you getting in the wedding
party for a long time or no
always you know
there's no reason yeah you dumb [ __ ] it
was the weekend huh there was no reason
not to but it was also like laundry day
so i was wearing this dress but the
underwear didn't
kind of quite go with it so i decided
i decide after a few drinks and i just
throw them away and i'm like whatever
anyway i got blackouts
in a bathroom comes out with no undies
yeah but here's the thing
not responsible enough to do that do you
know what i mean like i end up
their their their drink you could tell
we were still in our 20s i think they're
they're especially cocktail was like a
kamikaze shot
so if you're doing shots at a wedding
trash blacked
out so crab cakes are fine i woke up
yeah i woke up in a friend's bed and i
was like okay
like i literally i remember being like
ah i remember dancing to like some song
and then i woke up and was like okay
there's like there was like a giant
staircase and i guess i just was like
see you later and i went
down but no wonder we're on so i just
was sprawled out in the middle of this
hotel lobby just
puss a puss afloat just everywhere and
um
thank god it was in front of like her
family like there was
grandparents that probably were like oh
we didn't know that people are
shaving now you know like something so i
just heard the ring bear saw his first
labia
yeah i was supposed to like go sleep
over a friend's house and i remember he
called me the next day he's like you
never called me i was like
i didn't call anybody i woke up like in
my friends like the bride everybody the
whole bridal party took pictures of me
passed out like in the bed
yeah and then i just was like well see
you guys later and then i really haven't
talked to them since
really wow no we're friends on social
media but it was just one of those that
i was like that was uh
not one of my better showings did you go
did you get invited to anybody else's
wedding that was there like any of the
other
girls that were getting married i think
the other ones were no i wasn't close
enough
the other girls that i was close to
there had already gotten married and
nobody else that was close
gotcha yeah so you weren't like
blackballed from no no no i mean
again i think i was still a good time
you know even in my blackout stage
i don't know if ant helen but i just
like just
down like could you just imagine down a
spiral staircase because it's still kind
of like a classy type of staircase
it's the classiest staircase to fall
down yeah it would just gina in the wind
and so that's just
that was that gina in the way that was
uh that's not the name of the episode
that's the name of my next album john
song casey balcom is giant
like a giant
that was definitely an interesting one i
mean there's definitely been lots of
like uh
i i'm always a person like you know i
stay up the whole time you know i'm like
is there an after after party is there
an after after party like just
all of it are we all going in the pool
with [ __ ] are dresses on
i don't know how people have that
stamina without you know without
stimulants honestly
because it's it's like yeah dude they'd
stay for that and then you told me
your brother at the wedding he's closing
down the bar oh yeah like
45 heinekens no they were like they
closed it was on my sister's wedding and
you know uh it was a big nice event and
you know my family's all [ __ ] booze
bags so
they go hey my brother's trying to get a
drink they're like no we're close like
it's last call you gotta
everyone's leaving yeah yeah and he's
you know
starts [ __ ] you know what the [ __ ]
now you know not like causing a scene
but not not causing a scene right like
he was very close to a scene
right so my dad came over and was just
like you know hey you know like come on
like just
fight listen give him what he wants and
this will be over everything will be
fine yes
we'll solve your problems by giving him
just give him whatever he wants and then
go
all right listen you know what do you
want it cause i'll take 13 margaritas
i was like that's [ __ ] chestnut
checkers right there i gotta [ __ ]
respect that
did they give it did they give it to him
no they were like sorry we'll give you
two beers
which he took gladly oh yeah yeah and
then was like sleeping on the bus in two
seconds um
are you worried about the comics mixing
with your family
and non-comedians see here's the thing
we we don't have like a ton of fat like
because this might as well be the med
gala for us
like this is the nicest thing that we're
all gonna be attending tonight i know
i'm saying can i submit a packet
yeah yeah but it's 30 pages long
and it's all political no topic
i'll see you guys at the reception yeah
come by um
the thing is that we really don't have
like we have very there's only going to
be like
and i still call them grown-ups because
i just i i just you know at weddings
it's grown-ups and kids
it's mainly kids it's it's literally
like i think there's gonna be
there's six tables of comics one table
of tampa people
and then like our table with like our
family and a couple close friends from
home so that's mainly comics
comics are going to be running the assad
it's gonna inmates are running the
assignments mainly comics yeah but you
know what i did but you know what's
interesting i
you guys aren't sitting at the same
table i know for all parties involved
that's probably better
uh it's patreon.com folks um
i was like i wonder i split up a lot of
like uh like uh pairs karen and
christine aren't sitting together
wow i know i really like i really would
you to mix it up a little bit i know
i know but if i was just like you guys
are sitting with people you don't know
that would be weird sometimes i think
about that like the approach of like do
that they do that on purpose to cause
mingle
i know do you think that that's a good
thing i've been at bad tables
that's why i started smoking again
because i was at a bad table at a
wedding in
[ __ ] italy or wherever the [ __ ] we
were and you were like this [ __ ] i
was like this
[ __ ] sucks it was the worst half
table didn't speak english like booze
couldn't fix it no and it was
i mean they uh at that point it was just
red
uh it was just it was just wine at the
table
and i mean yeah i was like you could
have [ __ ] injected me with red wine
to get to take the edge off like there
was not enough white wine in the
building to get me
to have fun at that table that's the
thing is that wine will get you drunk
but it doesn't get you like
uppity drunk do you know what i mean
like wine you can you'll get [ __ ]
[ __ ] you'll you won't remember some
things you'll brown out and stuff like
that but you're not gonna be like
that's all not you're not gonna it
doesn't really give you the [ __ ] kick
you need some cold stuff you need a
vodka soda you need some coronas
who has the better table kippy or foley
i actually like both the tables a lot
really your table's called road hacks
your table is fat guys
your table's called nycc green room so
it's very fun you're with like cannon
and feeney you're with versi and emilio
uh and berg and yeah
yeah sold yeah we're gonna arm wrestle
but you guys are like next to each other
i just in the past being at a table
where you don't know people
i feel like you have to be on when it's
not just a family
i know it's nice but then it does get a
little like um
you know isolationist when it's like
when like the foleys are over here and
the mutant's a table nine yeah we have
like what we have is we have
five tables of ten in the middle and
then the the sides are it's four tables
of twenty four
so we've got like big old tables and
then the co and then five tables in the
middle and then like
how many people are coming to this event
like 146. one
but that's with four babies nice yeah
yeah so our original number one 170 yeah
well here's the thing too is
i told my sister i was like the babies
just have to stay up because you they're
like you can't leave the baby
and put a monitor like they won't let
you leave the baby alone so i don't even
know because the place is that there's
some rules there's
like proper review this document
i know what but i also feel like it's
not going to be like that when you get
there but because so many people have
gotten married like cannon got married
there he said it's a [ __ ] black oh
really nice yeah yeah yeah yeah i
figured the people that bring babies
you bring a nanny i always thought that
was classy well my sister
yeah well one of our friends was
bringing like grandma like so it's their
his mom and they have twins and then my
sister got her husband and her husband's
sister so i was like oh maybe auntie
blair has to go to bed early but she's
also single so i kind of want her to
like
have fun and maybe like you know get her
get her butt touched or something so
like
like i'm all for i that's the thing is
that we don't have a ton of single
friends now
you know what i mean sure like i i like
i think when if i had this wedding ten
years ago everybody would be [ __ ]
everybody and that's what that's like my
dream is that my friends just like oh
i would have been in the corner out on
the grass yeah
but now but now there's not a ton of
people that can touch each other's butts
but i still hope it happens
yeah i'll be kevin i'll be thinking
i'll be wherever you need me sir butt
touching for the for
the cause i'm in the security gang let's
talk about our good friends over there
at ladder right the best to love them
um life insurance is something that i've
always worried about i've never had
i've had opportunities to get it and i
haven't for this reason or for that
reason um
but then you start to look around you
think about the ones you love and you
know do you want to leave them with
nothing
um i mean we're coming out of a global
pandemic you're not we don't know what's
gonna happen that's exactly right why
not get a little protection nobody's
gonna live forever
uh you should check out ladder they can
help you out um why not pay
a little bit to make sure that the
people that you love to protect it
in the long run you guys choose ladder
ladder is 100 digital there's no doctors
no needles no paperwork
nothing like that you just need a few
minutes on the phone or laptop to apply
uh ladders smart algorithms work in real
time so you'll find out instantly if
you're approved uh if you prefer to talk
to a person their team is like
their team of licensed agents doesn't
work on commissions so they'll help you
they're not going to try to upsell you
you know what i mean they're just going
to try to find out what's best for you
there's no hidden fees you can cancel
any time get a full refund
if you change your mind in the first 30
days we're talking no risk over here
there you go
uh ladder policies are issued by
insurers with long proven histories of
paying claims
they are rated a and a plus by am
best nice i don't know what it is but
that sounds pretty good sounds classy uh
finally since life insurance cost
more as you age now is a time to cross
it off your list guys
true so go to ladderlife.com garbage
today
one more time that's ladderlife.com
garbage
to see if you're instantly approved
that's ladder l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com
garbage link will be in the description
ladderlife.com
garbage gang this podcast is sponsored
by our good friends over there at
better help let me tell you something
folks you know as we've gone over in the
podcast
people don't have it easy sometimes
sometimes you need a little help working
things through and our good friends at
betterhelp can help you with that
they don't just hand you pills they
don't just do that we're talking about a
registered counselor
that you could be speaking with within
48 hours on a global network basically
you can get them anywhere anytime
you'll be communicating with them in 48
hours and they're absolutely fantastic
yeah uh it's really easy you can log
into your account anytime send a message
to your counselor
uh you'll get timely and thoughtful
responses plus you can schedule weekly
video or phone sessions so you won't
ever have to sit in the uncomfortable
waiting room
with traditional therapy i did that and
i hated it i went to a guy that a lot of
other comics went to
and you would like hear your peers and
stuff you could hear them like crying
about their mom or their dad and you're
like
it's i don't want somebody hearing what
i'm saying you know so this is uh you
know all from the privacy of your own
home
uh it's more affordable than traditional
offline counseling and financial aid is
available if
you need it better help want you to
start living a happier life today
there you go you can visit their website
and read their testimonials
um they're all on there so visit
betterhelp.com
garbage that's better help h-e-l-p and
join over one million
people who have taken charge of their
mental health uh with getting help from
an experienced professional
uh in fact uh so many people have been
using betterhelp that they're now
recruiting counselors in all 50 states
look at that and i got a special offer
for our listeners
um which you guys have been using
because they've re-up so thank you so
much
yes i really appreciate you like just
[ __ ] if you're taking care of your
life is fantastic so a special offer
to see it for the ru garbage listeners
you get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
garbage one more time special offer for
are you garbage listeners you get 10
off your first month at betterhelp.com
garbage now back
to the show and then where are you
registered we didn't we we're like
you're doing cash
you want money yeah yes yeah type it up
for that
my friends don't need to buy me china
yeah yeah you know what i mean plus it's
it's now like rental cars are hella
expensive and people are like coming in
that we're also like again we're 40 we
have [ __ ] you know what i mean like i
don't i'm 40.
i'm 39 gross i know i
know i wouldn't have had you back at
pudding to be honest with you
if i would have known that this is only
for kids
um but no yeah we have a honeymoon fun
which is basically like
help us pay off the wedding where's that
oh i love that uh honeymoon we're going
to do
uh italy and i think we're going to do
like uh trying to pay for youtube bozos
to go to europe
malta dolomites and maybe south of
france you know we're gonna we haven't
been in
the south of france we're gonna go
everywhere
yeah well he has families there right no
his family's in spain
yeah south of france is just where all
the cheese and the wine and the flowers
oh so you're doing cash what would you
expect
two fine podcasts popping up standing
gentlemen to drop in they
think in mind we gotta cook in patreon
what would you want from two guys like
us
oh oh [ __ ] okay what could donate
[Applause]
what do you expect hey well listen i
like a hundred dollars is
from like hey from each of you from each
of you
okay fine all right all right all right
200 a piece give me three extra plates
so whatever you're having
200 a piece 200 a piece and a plus for
our date so four
no just 200 a piece i'm doing more than
that what are you doing that's fine i
got to talk to you
as as the ceo i mean i got to spend more
than you position
i'll write it down i'm not saying it out
loud okay we ask
every person who comes in here how much
they drop out of wedding you won't say
what you're gonna throw i know what i'm
doing
i'm doing three i'm doing four she just
made 700 bucks
three thousand dollars i'm publicly
saying four it's really going to be 250.
the foley system i like all of this i
know i'm just happy that like
you know as you get older your friends
can actually even put 100 i remember in
college it would just be like me
and 10 friends and we'd all throw 20
bucks in an envelope and hand it to the
couple like
bad have you ever not given a gift i for
sure have not because i don't know
oh yes that that's a part of the story
of my own my one family friend got
married
i was in kind of a bad mental place at
the time because you're stable now
congratulations you're doing better i
was i was young and angry
um but it was in the middle of [ __ ]
july
and i had to wear this thing and it was
all outside
all right now is this all outside um no
because the pavilion is inside but
there's big doors and then there's a
little bar right across the way and then
there's a ball so you can go in
somewhere and cool off
it's going to be cool yeah this is not
going to be this thing
there was nothing inside you were just
outside that's a lot
dude it was like it was like a heat wave
bugs it wasn't a tent no
fans so i started drinking yingling
lagers
all right and next thing you know i'm
[ __ ] hammered
damn hammer drunk like we we left as a
family me my mom my dad my brother
because i was so drunk i like beer
hammered
i know i got in the car and i started
crying i'm having like this
meltdown my dad's driving he's like what
the [ __ ] with this guy
and i never give them a gift so
when i would see there i would see them
periodically like you know a couple
months later you'd see them at like
a cookout or you'd see them at christmas
or thanksgiving i'm like oh
sorry i forgot that i want to make sure
i get it to you and blah blah blah and
never gave it to them
i've that i've had that i have that
currently with like three people
all things no i haven't it feels like
chains on you
it does i do wake up in the middle of
the night sometimes and go
yeah i think i think literally
almost every wedding i've gone to i
haven't given anything that's why i
i was poor i was a comic i was like
working at restaurants i was just like
if i'm gonna fly to [ __ ] hawaii i'm
sorry i can't give you a gift when
they'd probably rather not have me there
and just have the gift you know they
probably like just
send something to them we don't need
someone showing their [ __ ] cooch in
the lobby
that one i didn't show by cooking casey
get you for your wedding
her [ __ ] no at that wedding i sweet
talk to
sweet talk to cop to like not find
somebody or something like that
i remember i took a picture with him and
i had to send it to robbie to be like
just in case this floats around the
internet it was just me on a cop like me
oh this was recent that was a couple
years ago i mean you're with robbie so
yeah it wasn't it wasn't
i feel like your wedding is gonna have a
jagermeister tag i wish
uh do you guys remember sponsored by
monster energy drink
sponsored by cushy dreams
pretty sweet yeah no i've never given
gifts i've been really bad like that but
i've just always been [ __ ] poor
yeah well poor in the sense that like i
always spent my money on stupid [ __ ] and
never had enough
you know like poor in the sense that i
would just go out and [ __ ] booze it
up or buy
[ __ ] stupid clothes or something sure
the thing that haunts me
and and obviously we know that nobody
forgets that
i know people say oh it doesn't matter
it [ __ ] met they are clocking
every move you make sure you don't get
the thank you card of course
they're not like thanks for coming yeah
they don't care yeah
i know although microcosm is 150. i
think i forgot to give
somebody uh a gift for their wedding by
accident and i still got the thank you
card
oh and i think it was kind of like you
[ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
yeah i remember who it was i've gotten
asked afterwards like
hey what yeah he's been confronted i've
been confronted
by who by you know family no
an associate a friend yeah
hey couldn't help but notice hey i know
i saw your big head [ __ ]
sucking down filet tips i was in the
wedding you were in the wedding i don't
think you should have to buy a gift
if there's a wedding in the [ __ ] suit
i'm into the hotel you have to do
everything traveling that's
cheapo [ __ ] and i i also i didn't have
the money what's this guys i had about
40 dollars in my account the day of the
wedding yep
what did this guy say to you it was
though it was the lady
and uh she was
who were you friends with a guy proper
both of them yes
all right i was gonna say no it wasn't
like she starts piping up man
you know straighten your lady and no i
just got like a
giner in the wind i don't even notice
bird what's the deal
[Laughter]
because that would be embarrassing yeah
if your friend's girlfriend
i think it was like uh never see me
again it was
more like hey we just want to make sure
it didn't get lost i was like you know
it didn't get lost
like oh it got lost oh that was that's a
very powerful i left it right there on
the cake i put it right in between the
bride and the groom
i also this is pretty trashy so i went
to another one this was maybe a couple
of years ago
and uh same thing day of
like i think it was just like trap we
got it was in philly we got there late
we're running behind
enough time to stop and get a card or
whatever so i'm like i'll just [ __ ]
mail one
and which i think the rule of thumb is
you have up until like you have a year
you have one year one year provide your
gift and that's still being social these
are 50s rules
no they are whatever i've always been in
my favor
yeah i i'm like oh i have a year and
then like two years past
that's that's the the big that's the
worst thing because you go i got six
more months to push this down to
you know kick this down the road but i
uh i [ __ ] i didn't go give the gift
or whatever and i was like [ __ ] i'm
gonna get in front of this right
and i'd go in with my wife too so she
was like we gotta like she's on top like
we got it but like it's my friend so
like she doesn't know how to contact a
person to get like an address or
anything
so i'm like oh what's your address or
something and wait you were with your
girl at this time
with yeah with my wife really yeah yeah
wow a couple of years ago suppressed she
let that slide
i told him like it's american you know
that's a real
things are different things are
different over here all right we get
it's actually an insult
we get 10 years to give a gift after a
wedding
we give it on the day of here's their
funeral
you wanted bit we wait and see how
things go for a couple of years
and uh she
i i forget what happened and then
i was like [ __ ] i i wasn't confronted i
forget how it came up but i was like oh
[ __ ] i did mail it
and i hadn't nice and she goes welcome
to the dark side she goes yeah our mail
always gets [ __ ] up
that doesn't enact mine too same thing
crazy she's like send to this address
and i'm like what i'm like i'm just
going to venmo it to you i just venmo
right then
i said here's like 300 bucks or whatever
jesus
i was like i'm getting this you want the
money you don't want my card
what i'm not going to i'm not going to
the post office i'm not going to the
store
take the [ __ ] cash end of
transactions good for her
garbage though that that's guard on her
end 100
what there has to be certain listen
there's scumbags
sure all right three at this table right
now and one of the corners
[Laughter]
check please i forgot the one in the
corner it's like one of those things to
make sure you're not a robot
the captcha yeah don't forget about
t-bone
mark all the scumbags you see in this
picture
but there has to be there has to be
um etiquette in the world and most
people have to abide by that
people with like regular jobs that are
getting married that have families
they got to be the ones who look the
other way and take the high road
toby said you can't have that i don't
think i was confronted i think it came
up of like oh it can't all be dirt bags
because if we're all dirt bags and
nobody can dirt bag
and if i can't dirtbag what's the point
what's the point of living i know
i don't like i don't like your
independence day speech
i can't be a piece of [ __ ] nobody gets
to be a piece of [ __ ]
you're gonna come here from another
planet and tell me i can't be a piece of
trash it's
my god-given american right no i do i i
just i
actually don't like the idea that we
have to buy
i don't like the idea of these
registries i don't like the idea
that we have to buy people i don't know
their kitchenware i just think it's
so weird weird i think it's super dated
um
and i also think that there should be
etiquette rules with like if you have a
destination wedding you're not getting
any gifts yes
there's no there's no i have come i have
come to a different country
like you are not going to get anything a
tough look yeah it's a nice vacation but
it's a tough look i mean i think you
give a card and just say
so happy for you guys and and you know
you'd be you don't like
break anything when you're at the
wedding but i don't think we should have
to buy people [ __ ] dishes no
just don't think that but is that is
that our financial situation saying that
like if what if you were a millionaire
you would you would still give a gift
right i would probably still
i would feel like money is just never a
bad idea right you can't go what i mean
cold hard a little bit of ghee yeah
that's what i'm just saying are we like
bitching about the destination weddings
and no you shouldn't have to give
is that because we don't have money if
you had money you'd be like yeah give a
gift of course
i mean maybe yeah
zoom out most people to go say you're
going to the [ __ ] dominican republic
to get married or whatever
it's like that's a that's 12 hundo this
sounds personal but
i did go but i was still like as a uh
not i just picked that um
i swear to god i swear to god uh
if you have to go dominican republic in
2012
it might have been 2012. honestly i'm
just picking numbers but i'm just saying
it's like
it's also like people go oh it's a
vacation it's like yo it's a vacation
with everybody from your wedding like i
wouldn't choose to my va
my vacation wouldn't be like hey let's
go hang out with john's family you
wouldn't even
be able to exactly so it's like you
don't get a full vacation
right you're paying a bunch of money for
to do what they want to do when like
to be on their schedule or whatever so
yeah it is a little wonky
it's like i i've unless i really wanted
to go or they were really close to me
i'm not going on any destination
weddings yeah just not having i like the
face roll given a nice gift
you like to what i like the face throw
of giving a nice gift
yeah you know what i mean yeah you like
to be like this is that people like see
and they're like oh my god
i'm signing it
250. i love it i love it i give you a
bitcoin you think i care
dude you are presented with a very
unique opportunity with your wedding
all you have to do is invite all the
comics onto your podcast there just give
them a hug like come to my podcast and
then everybody gets to write off
everything they spend at the wedding
i mean it's not bad just gonna do it
anyway but okay cody's gonna sign your
check
so yeah all right i got three weeks to
invite to about 140 podcasts
that would be so [ __ ] exhausting i
wouldn't even make it tomorrow you don't
have to record the pockets
you've got to talk about every single
every single
i'll think about doing the podcast that
way i get to write it off you get to
write it off
i put my room under are you garbage did
you
i'm going to [ __ ] deny that charge
also to hear how trashy and just
hot you know shitty we are we were on
the road and we ordered it was like
three in the morning after the shows and
drinking and we ordered like a hundred
and fifty dollars worth of tacos or
something oh yeah
and the card got flagged it was like is
this your purchase i had to be like yes
i am buying 158
worth of tacos at 3am i like that they
couldn't just tell by the llc that says
are you garbage and they look and
they're like these guys are definitely
buying
800 worth of [ __ ] taco bell right now
well we're excited we can't wait
i'm so excited it's going to be a good
time yeah i i think it's going to be
i hope it's you know most will have to
have you on for maybe a patreon episode
to do a recap oh yes
yeah because it's like it's so much
because you know when you're planning a
wedding it's like
you have to remember that weddings they
don't as long as there's alcohol and
food like people are going to be [ __ ]
that's all i care about you know what i
mean i mean the booze cold
a couple of good potatoes yeah a decent
piece of meat what's your
cake situation we're doing doughnuts
really yeah
because here's my thing on the cakes too
it's there's so much [ __ ] money
they're like
800 to a thousand dollars for something
that sits there and then
when it's cut and put out most people
are like dancing so it just sits at the
chat
nobody you know what i mean nobody eats
it so we're just the um since it's in
the hudson valley or wherever we're
gonna just do apple cider donuts and
they have like some uh cookies and
fruits that they put out in coffees and
stuff like that i don't mind it
i don't i it's and it's also like way
cheaper
like here's the thing we're doing an
expensive wedding on the the cheapest
way we can do it it's two days so it's
[ __ ] like you know it's
it's not cheap but also we're not
spending money on things that don't
matter to us
i've never thought about my cake we
don't have you know like i don't there's
certain things that i'm just like
yeah whatever whatever my shoes are from
amazon like i'm not going to buy
bachelor michigan like 100
shoes you can't even [ __ ] see
underneath the gown like i could give a
[ __ ] you know and i'm pretty sure you're
gonna be dancing barefoot right my
sister's
every every girl gets barefoot at their
wedding yeah do you have it another
thing i want to talk about casey's gonna
be
bonkos i yeah have you assigned a
handler do you have a handler ready to
go for you
also do you have a party you have a
wedding party are you just doing youtube
it's just me it's just my sister and his
sister
so that's sweet yeah yeah yeah so
because again like i think when you're
older you just realize like i i don't
want to put
i don't need it like i just it's just me
and rob plus we're already married i
mean yeah you guys got married [ __ ]
six years ago
this whole thing's a shame folks these
cameras aren't even plugged in
so this is yeah it is just really like
us being like
oh in front of all of our friends will
you guys keep us accountable
for not being dicks too each other
you're the listener this guy is the
money grab that's what this is that's
right
i want the cash baby this got pushed
like 18 it was supposed to be in march
right yeah yeah yeah so it's been pushed
a bunch of times it got pushed it was
supposed to be may then it was in
october
and then when we picked this july date
there was still a ton of restrictions
like it was still like footloose it was
like you could only dance at your tables
you can't hug anyone
everybody has to wear matt and none of
the places were open so everything was
gonna have to be outside
so luckily we were like you know what i
think july is going to be good and then
so now we have like this pavilion and
this barn and this like
this little bar that is on there i can't
wait for you guys to see it it is so
old school it's like all wooden with
like the green lanterns like it's so
[ __ ] it's so cool me and robbie were
both like if we can't have that place we
might just cancel the wedding
like like it was like the little bar
area was so
cool like it was such part of like the
experience there but but
yeah i'm excited now we can all like
just lick things and like you know
yeah take our shoes off do you have any
weird is there going to be any weird
uh like traditions where like you take
the they're doing the
chairs the jew chairs yeah i don't think
that's proper
[Laughter]
i'm fake jewish because like i found i
found out that my
i didn't do you guys don't know the
story that i was like so my whole life
people have been like you're jewish and
i'm like i'm not like when i lived in
hawaii people would literally
which is so not actually cool tables
would be like i'm sorry we're just
arguing what are you
because i they thought it was persian
they thought it was like uh you know
you're very all you know yeah you
weren't irish a lot of people i am irish
but
i thought i was russian and then i was
visiting my aunt for her 100th birthday
like she literally was like oh well you
know being 100 jewish with my
mom and i was like i'm sorry what'd you
say she's like i'm 100 jewish which
means my grandpa was
my grandpa lived with us and he was 100
jewish and i asked my dad my dad
was like yeah growing up they just told
us not to talk about it so like my
i didn't know that i had so it's not
like real because it's not my mom but i
did not know i was jewish
wow robbie's like your face has always
known yeah
yeah you look like every girl went to
high school very jewish
uh but i had no [ __ ] idea but so yeah
we're doing the i know they're not
called jew chairs but that's
that's what i told my venue we're doing
the jew chairs
to get a good deal
we're going to break the glass and then
we're going to uh we're going to do
yeah we're going to break it but i read
that we're just going to break a light
bulb in a bag because i heard that's
easier to break than actual glass
come on that's the trashiest thing i've
ever [ __ ] you're breaking a light
bulb i'm not going to this wedding
you we just went from you just went from
a fictional 400 that was really 250.
we're going to crush it later with a
rock
i got a couple of m80s we're going to
set up i was
on the googles and i was like do it
because i was all of a sudden i was like
oh i probably have to get like a certain
glass
what is happening and then on amazon it
was like oh you can get these glasses
and they're
thirty dollars and sixty i'm like i'm
not gonna [ __ ] buy a thirty dollar
glasses
well that's yeah people say a wine glass
but then somebody was like oh a light
bulb's just really easy to break and i
was like and that made sense to me
don't tell anybody else yeah that's a
[ __ ] insane
a light bulb that's gotta be bad luck or
something gonna make the noise
yeah you can't use an ashtray or
something like that get a glass come on
i'll bring i'll bring a [ __ ] uh i
mean what's a wine glass
i'll bring a white but then it's a lot
okay i'll bring a stemless wine glass
there you go yeah you can't you can't be
stepping on 60 watts that's [ __ ] nice
you wrap it in a [ __ ] you wrap it in
like a napkin or a bag yeah
no not a bag it's that bad who's the
fish eating this thing don't you
don't you have like a rabbit wallace no
we have robbie's friend so
it's her bodega mommy you want to get
married
crushing an arizona cane
yeah he's making us delightful paninis
and then pronouncing us
i do no it's robbie's robbie's friend
that is like uh ordained and he's
married all of robbie's other friends
and so we told him where we want to do
the glass thing and then he's like well
but neither of us really know what it
meant and then we were googling it and
it was like
that has like a bunch of different
meetings but he's like i'll find the
better one because the real meaning is
like
it represents like the temples of
jerusalem being taken down i'm like well
we don't
that's not what we want on our way
saturday let's keep it light
but still got some bocce ball to play
after this thing buddy
buddy it's a monday have we even talked
about how trashy is getting married on a
[ __ ] monday that's great
um monday at 7 00.
man who's doing the monday the monday
evening wedding same time jeopardy
the monday light bulb
[Laughter]
this thing really is it's like lipstick
on a pit like
the place is beautiful everything's
you're just
doing it as trashy as you possibly can
it's going to be a blast but you just
talked about smashing a light bulb
instead of a glass i know
because i listen you know robbie it's
not and i forgot it was on a monday
yes it's we we're doing a sunday month
sunday to tuesday extravaganza well you
everybody works on saturdays
as a comedian it makes sense it's also
and it's way cheaper half the [ __ ]
yeah exactly but
it also now that it's in july there's
the pool is open it's going to be
something it's going to it's really
yeah i got my one piece out but you guys
i just threw up in my mouth
please bring floaties
but uh uh no i i i
just i read uh well you've seen robbie
that's what i was gonna say so do you
think he could break a regular glass
yeah of course he's a light he's a
gentle man
it's a white wine glass it's not stone
cold
i would love a few people's elbow the
glass
okay so no light bulb okay fine i'll get
a wine glass yeah get a wine class this
is [ __ ]
bonkers i like the donuts it's great
love those doughnuts those apple cider
donuts
and then the night before what are we
talking bar here
bars open bar but it's i was scared to
ask honestly i didn't want to bring the
mood down that bar that you're talking
that's open bar
yes the only thing that's not so the the
barbecue is hosted anything that's at
the little bar
is cash but we had we're hosting two
hours at the barbecue and i think the
wedding is like six or seven six hours
so six
hours and then two hours afterwards
they're going to be
cash bar but i'm going to bring cash
that's fine that's like that's like
going to the hotel
yeah yeah yeah yeah it's like six hours
is great but hold on the day before
what's going on now so there's the
barbecue right
and then so that's two hours and that's
just like uh ribs and chicken and peach
cobbler like great and then we're doing
the roasts and toasts so people can
toast us or roast us
i think my mom's gonna dance to a song i
don't [ __ ] know what's gonna happen
that's open bar
that's no that's that's that's cash bar
okay because that's going to be over at
the little bar and we'll have like
s'mores and stuff but again like i have
a feeling what about the chicken is that
on the house
yeah the barbecue is hosting charging at
450 for a chicken sandwich
the barbecue no no hey mrs let me get it
two pieces
we're in the weeds back here barb's back
there slinging coleslaw
we need ones get them from the safe
no no no we're hosting we're hosting
yeah it's just anything at the little
old school bar is not hosted because
it just it yeah so because it's because
we're doing two days and then we're
hosting the breakfast
the brunch the day after no i would
never really yeah we're hosting the
brunch and then i'm also gonna have like
the day of the wedding as i'm getting
ready i'm going to buy a bunch of
champagne so people can stop by and have
a moza with me
or they can hang with robbie yeah you
have 140 people doing mimosas
you got to think about the heat too i'll
get to you i know
yeah yeah no it's gonna be a nightmare
i'm gonna sweat through my dress i'm
gonna fall down
it's gonna be great it's gonna be
awesome i'm gonna ruin my shoes
i'm gonna ruin my i'd make everybody put
their cell phones in those bags that you
put in
do you think about that key party no
yonder bag yeah like a dave chappelle
show
true yeah yeah i'll be like nobody
i like how your mind went to the orgy
real quick i i'm just i
pitched that nobody wanted to do it
wishful thinking you know like i said
there's not going to be a lot of
grown-ups there so if you want to
i love how you're calling them grown-ups
you're 40. i still call them groceries i
know
i know growing up but again a lot of i
would say there's going to be is there
going to be a lot of parents there
no there's literally only going to be my
dad his girlfriend my mom her boyfriend
robbie's that's a tough statement yeah
my dad his broad
two guys my mom seen and
[Laughter]
flavor of the week yeah and then
robbie's parents and then one of our
friends moms that's it
you're gonna have to put ndas next to
the salad forks i mean truly
we like nothing you saw here i don't
think there is salad forks
[Applause]
grab a handful of lettuce and coal today
you eat the corn on the cob with your
hands
i hope everybody likes fish fillets for
dinner
what's the menu what are we talking
about on the menu okay okay so the night
before like i said it's like
it's like barbecue chicken with all
these sauces ribs uh cornbread mac and
cheese salad
peach cobbler and brownies and then the
wedding is either
the duck or the beef because they had a
whole thing and
we were like oh should we get chicken or
salmon like but robbie likes duck and i
like steak so we're like [ __ ] it let's
just do
i like that what we like um so it's duck
or steak or the vegetarian option is
gnocchi and then there's a salad that
comes with it
veggies twice baked potatoes love uh-huh
a two-b
take it out chop it up mix some stuff in
pipe it back oh yeah oh and then the
appetizers like for cocktail it's uh
coconut shrimp and
uh smoked salmon like toast and then
like a big cheese
and like veggie and meat thing very nice
and then late night
at the bar it'll be chicken fingers and
fries and like probably a bunch of like
we'll
get some costco snacks things that glow
in the dark ring pops you know
all the [ __ ] i like it yeah no there'll
be food oh bro
yeah no the food you might be back up to
250 by the way
[Laughter]
i don't know if there's gonna be chicken
dentists there's gonna be chicken
tenders
late night maybe a couple saws we don't
know yet yeah
yeah and then and then and then i have
somebody we're gonna walk around with
cigarettes cigars and joints
and like one of those little like i have
irene walking around
like uh like a vegas showgirl like a
little
box that's gonna have uh we i bought i
made us matches that say
do you remember from my um my uh my
invite was two souls one whisper my
invite was two souls become one
whisperer it makes no sense but i loved
it
so i have matches and then joint cigars
and cigarettes so
party classy classy what kind of cigs
uh coffee strikes no you know what i
don't sell them here
really no that's what i smoke in europe
uh
that's what i smoke in europe somehow
that didn't sound classy now
it's all i could find in europe that's
how i read it ah
no i instantly thought eastern when you
said that eastern europe yeah no we'll
probably just do marble lights
maybe some new ports there you go
newport pretty crazy
you smoke newbies sometimes i like a
menthol have you met this woman
i mean that's what i started on and it
was yeah everybody starts off yeah
because nobody when people bum
them they people will ask you for a
cigarette you're like it's a newport and
they'll be like never mind
yeah not you you roll the sleeves up and
dive in lucky strikes and newports
robbie's got himself an angel i say is
there hundreds
got any 120s back there or you get the
parliament so you can do cocaine in the
tip you know i can't wait till robbie's
smashing the fluorescent light bulb
sword fights like a long one um
all right let's get into some patreon
questions here we're all excited we
can't wait before we get in the patreons
finish the story about the suit i'm
sorry i cut you off bonobos
oh i went to a place where i got my suit
for the
for my wedding very fancy suit supply i
think it's a dutch company what'd you
drop
we'll get into that so i so i went to i
went there because they treat you like
[ __ ]
you go in they're like you want an
espresso do you want a diet coke
whatever and this is the first time i'm
walking in confidently with money not
emptying out my bank account to get a
suit
and not being like hey i'm looking i'm
going to come back on page so just pants
i just need a belt man
you have anything in the back laying
around you get it hem somewhere else
oh yeah i like how you called it hemmed
that's how you know your trash an old
mom thing cam get it
tailored you get sue taylor taylor you
get your pants let out or hemmed
yeah that's what i do can you let these
out in the waist a little bit
i never understood how that worked let
them out of the way tighten it up in the
crotch a little bit
take a little from the crotch put it in
the waistband you're just gonna give
this kid a leg up
so dude talk about like i
i i felt like [ __ ] uh pretty woman or
whatever no one they wouldn't
they wouldn't serve me i'm over there
trying jackets on by myself like a
[ __ ] [ __ ]
not one guy i was in there for 12
minutes and i was furious some guy goes
oh you're you're good right and walked
away
i'm sitting there trying jackets on i'm
like i'm going to take my [ __ ]
hard-earned patreon dollars somewhere
else
so i walked down there to bonobos those
[ __ ] jerk-offs
and she goes listen are you familiar
with bonobos i've heard it on podcasts
and strike one yeah she goes uh
i bought your suit with a promo promo
code you made it weird
um so i go in
[Laughter]
and this this is how you know we're tr
like
we don't know how to act because she
goes okay this is what we do we'll try
you try on a suit
we'll find out your sizes then we'll
find out what we have in your size and
we'll we'll mail it to you
you know what i mean whatever styles you
choose you get to try it on
and all that and i go okay cool so we
got we get all fitted and she goes i
have this one
in your size and i wanted to like gray i
go okay cool
bada bing bada boom she goes oh i also
have this one it's a tan one
like you know like a khaki she's like
that might be cool too i go
because i can send you that when i go
all right let's do it yeah she goes oh i
have the same one in linen and lennon's
really nice for this summer
yeah they're male 1 you don't try and
just try it on the store and get this
over with because they don't have them
in the store
you try on a suit and then all their
suits are the same like cut and size
they just send you that color they just
send you the call like this and you try
them on
you're like really [ __ ] idiots no so
they go she's like and this one i can
say this one too
all right and then she hands me a
[ __ ] ipad with a bill for 39 hundo on
it that
she wants right then and there i said yo
no
i'm not just buying these [ __ ] suits
to try them all and then what do you do
send them back the ones you don't want
you send them back and then you get it
that's the same [ __ ] the [ __ ] hotel
does with holding the [ __ ]
uh credit card over are you still mad at
chicago marriott's still holding your
fifth
yeah so i was like they're beacon my
action i figured it was like uh we'll
send you
like we'll keep your credit card on file
we'll send you this whatever you don't
send back in two weeks we'll bill you
oh yeah yeah no she wanted the 39 hundo
up front
how did how are you doing business like
that i said and also exchanges
you said send and she was like i'll send
you this one and send you that one and
send you this one i go yeah [ __ ] sure
so you're walking right now so i i
bought the suit
kind of sight unseen which one the tan
one no it's a gray one give me one
suit on carfax it's got some rear end
damage
holy [ __ ] um yeah it was 7.50
so you might be getting 150 now i think
about it
just give me the jacket when you're done
i'll leave robbie my pants
yeah yeah i'm like kevin's giving us a
suit for the wedding
shoot the shoes see if you like the
shoes
no so i got 20 off so it was six hundo
out the door
nice which i'm probably going to return
after the wedding return the suit
keep the tags on i like that you you've
pulled that move i'm sure right
she's probably got tags on her right now
no i pulled them off
but i definitely i've i've gotten better
with it because i used to just shop
recklessly and just the minute i got
home ranking
take all the tags off and then get it
and be like this and now i really i
i'll leave him on for a bit but i'm
getting better with i'm getting more
like comfortable online shopping knowing
that you can return things i used to
never be able to like hit
by like because you know when you see
because you again like you see the price
even though you know like okay i'm gonna
return three of these sometimes that
math doesn't add up in my head
the second i spend it it's done yeah
sometimes when i see it and i'll be like
oh 250
i'm like oh no and even though i know
i'm only gonna keep fifty dollars worth
of stuff
i still sometimes can't hit check out my
my wife does that she'll order like four
of the same things yeah yeah yeah
and then next thing you know we have
like 350 worth of h m genes we have
right right right right yeah it's now my
responsibility to return yeah yeah yeah
yeah because you got to return it at the
spot right i thought you didn't send it
back but then it's like you got to go to
the [ __ ] yeah i've got
ended up with that over at uh
because she gets it delivered and then
all of a sudden it's saturday i'm trying
to watch my highlights and hang out
i gotta [ __ ] run into the city don't
you mean read your highlights
[Laughter]
i like that goofus and gallant um yeah
yeah i'm lucky now that we have uh a
doorman downstairs so there's like a
male thing a what a doorman
a doorman you are a garbage lady
a doorman a kevin a doorman
yeah but you have wait i'm shocked you
as a doorman
regardless of she said they got a nice
building they're doing all right over
there
a doorman doorman i i
sometimes a doorman sometimes when
there's man on the end i do start to
minute like i say like
it's not homeless man like spiderman
like
holy [ __ ] holy [ __ ] it's spiderman
sounds like somebody's dentist batman oh
[ __ ] it's batman spiderman i gotta get
spiderman to take this [ __ ] spiderman
my doorman
uh yeah jerry spiderman
that's what i'm saying i make him i make
him more of a person
he's orthodontist jerry spiderman
i got a root canal with mr spiderman
yeah my door
my doorman uh but we have just a thing
downstairs that's like ups usps
yeah and i bought like little envelopes
so i can just stick and
tape so i just stick it and i can just
bring it downstairs which is nice
because yeah if i had to walk to a post
office i wouldn't return anything
i'd live with everything sure i i have a
lot
currently that i have like six things
that i have and then that i'm not going
to yeah if it's after 21 days or
something then you just own it and
you're like well
i have a certified letter at the post
office i have to go pick up oh that
i hate that my name better not be
anywhere on that documentary i'm well
aware it's not
certified letters are the worse it's
like just send it yeah don't make me
sign for it don't make me look at you in
the eyes and say i received this
yeah well they do that because their
scumbag is like i don't know what
happened i didn't get it i don't know
what it is my grampies don't send me
a certified mail not a check i know that
much the letters of him talking about
our family tree
like you don't need to certify this
that's an old school thing
certified mail make sure they get it
yeah and then i just turn union
yeah i just open it up and it'd be a
picture like an 1800s picture that was
like you were related to this guy
and i'm like i don't care he's jewish
don't tell anybody
i know all right uh yeah oh so let's
transfer really we got to get a couple
of questions here we got a couple of
mini
but we're looking forward to it's going
to be fun i'm looking forward to it buds
and i have you guys staying i told you
you guys are like your rooms are kind of
next to each other kippy you got a
couple balconies so you guys can smoke
some smokes
you're right across i got a i got a
private john right
yes yeah yes but i'm paying for it yeah
yeah just right over the document they
emailed me again today i got to reserve
the room
yeah i already did that preserved it
25 bucks yeah 25. and the 25 to be able
to do that that's why you got out in
front of yeah i did mine yeah 25 bucks
bozo
the 25 you guys paid last time too is is
going to be applied to it
i forgot unless i paid 25 don't think i
forgot about that 25 bucks
that's why i didn't pay this one yet it
does the math on the card well it's 300
minus the 99
minus the 25
yeah um all right this one let's run
through a couple of questions here okay
uh this is actually a wedding this is
from uh
al michaels uh hey garbage fam
is it i'm going to a wedding and i'm a
bit confused if the money i give them is
supposed to be hand-to-hand or in a car
jesus [ __ ] mikey whispers over you
yeah
if it's at a vfw i think you can go
hand-to-hand yeah
anywhere else put it in a [ __ ] car or
venmo i'm a big uh
i'm a big uh money money thing guy
what's it called money holder
rather than a card piggy bank no
give them the pictures cards that have
the little slot in them for money yeah
they're different they're
like they're shaped like they're yeah
they're long yeah yeah yeah i like those
ones too but
definitely a card and you know what's
classy is some of those things have
little holes where the face of the
president
is so you know what you're getting you
ever see one of those yeah when i was
seven
yeah you can't be giving one of those
out of the [ __ ] classy wedding like
ben franklin you know what i mean great
graduation can't give those to somebody
on a monday night wedding
gotta come classy come correct all fives
i'm gonna give you one of those money
bouquets do it oh yeah can you make me a
money necklace
you know people like fold a bunch of
ones and i'm like now i can't spend this
you're going to really make me
unwrap a [ __ ] necklace that's right
buy a burger
no thank you doing it at the burger king
how much is it real quick uh all right
this one's from chris scott every you
shampoo is body wash
all the time i love it for years yeah i
love it conditioner is great for shaving
your legs
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah but
absolutely you know whatever whatever's
liquid in the shower
it's all the same [ __ ] if it's cleaning
hair can clean skin vice versa
i'm fine with it especially when they
come up with those two and one things
when they started that [ __ ] i was
like that's a free-for-all now
yeah like if you're really with
toothpaste yeah if you've ever like
camped or been in like a cabin or
something a lot of times that's all they
only
have like one thing yeah sure whatever
yeah yeah
i used to love i liked i genuinely like
the way
shampoo smells over soap
like you get like a nice herbal [ __ ]
like lady shampoo
herbal essences ocean breeze yeah put
that on like one of those
those scrunchies things in the shower oh
man get all lathered up it's the best
shout out to strawberry suave the best
shampoo ever
thanks no bob's trash
suaven v05 hit the bricks but when i was
a kid v05 that was [ __ ]
money no it wasn't it was never 305 and
jordas jeans come on
vo5 they did have like a hot oil that i
remember like that was like something
like everyone's grandma was like i'm
gonna hide away on my hair tonight
because it was salon level
some executives saw you coming from a
mile away
favorite flavors artificial water i've
always thought i've always thought you
look like a v05 guy
absolutely
this is from e05000 carlson um has a
family member ever given you an iou for
a birthday or christmas
no but casey's getting one for her
wedding uh i've never gotten an iou
i've have you given an i or you've
gotten an iou
i feel like i've definitely written a
card that was like i owe you
uh like something but i i definitely my
mom's
my mom has owed me a chair yeah my mom
sewed me a chair for
her last birthday yes i've definitely i
think i've definitely had one of those
like
as soon as my check clears you're yeah
the check clears you're gonna get 50 big
ones well my thing is i have that oh my
intention is always to pay or give the
gift i'm just never liquid enough to do
it sure what i mean
i've gotten in the past um
we've we've gotten the picture of the
thing in a card
right like me and my brother like hey
you guys are going to get this
are you jealous with the [ __ ] massage
chair yeah
that's [ __ ] exactly yeah you got that
with a basketball hoop
still waiting on it you got it like a
year later yeah it was a while
yeah i think i've definitely sent
something that was like i owe you i owe
you a dinner
i'm gonna take you out sometime i think
i've definitely told robbie a couple
times during christmas like i'm working
on it
like because i was gonna make him this
like this like book with like pictures
in it but that was like two years ago i
still have the book i'm just gonna
pronounce the picture
making presents that's that's a bad look
yeah you got the macaroni
especially if you're making it for your
husband we weren't married yet also he
waited six years to propose so
yeah he will get a photo book and he
will like it
well i mean he was gonna propose the
first day he met you yeah we knew each
other for four years he coulda
yeah i mean you were dating for six
years we were dating
six and a half years six and you knew
each other so you've known each other
ten years
yes damn i know that's what i'm saying
i should have got we should have it
should have happened there you go who
would have had a pre-pandemic wedding
oh you would have gotten for sure
no gift for me because i didn't have any
money i waited for your guys's patreon
to get more successful and then i was
like now we shall win
that's another thing too you got a lot
of friends on the come up these days
i know it's kind of cool you're going to
pull in a couple of fazels for this
thing i hope especially with some of
that guest list
going to be some serious coins who's the
most famous person going schultzy
uh gotta be i would assume yeah i guess
yeah sir there also might be some
surprise guests
like on a show i think louie's in town
probably more like open micros running
the catering
yeah yeah working on the savvy i hear
that's great um
all right let's see here let's do two
more um
this is have you ever and this is just
nuts have you ever rented the same exact
car you owned just to swap out parts
that's a good idea though that's pretty
ingenious i feel like somebody asked us
that sometime too that is [ __ ]
garbage man
i don't know man when you rent a car you
rent a car for a day that's probably
what 30 40 bucks
you get a whole new set of tires and a
radio yeah how do you return it
you pay for the extra insurance that
cover it wait really
really oh yeah i read a whole thread on
this a guy swapped out a whole engine
out of a rental car
and put his yeah he put his bunk engine
in the hole and he probably got it for
like 15 bucks for the day or whatever
yep you got to have like energy to do
that you know i mean you gotta you gotta
really plan this out and be like my dad
is gonna spend doing car [ __ ] i just
i have no desire i'd rather the car
break down and
i don't even have one yeah that's
exactly i'm not smart enough to be that
frugal
yeah you gotta have a skill set and be
broke yeah yeah
yeah yeah you gotta be real [ __ ]
handy yeah i guess i knew how to work on
cars it'd be like yeah let's get a
couple tires but i
yeah i have no idea yeah just get a job
as a mechanic
you wouldn't have to swap it out you
could afford here and get a new car sure
the guy is a [ __ ] mechanic there's no
there's no way
no weekend warriors for changing on an
engine on a toyota corolla
you need a [ __ ] setup you invite a
couple friends over i got some bud
lights if you can take this engine out
it's like they're helping you move kia
rio
we gotta
yeah it's a very gentle suv it's cool
he's got a kid too yeah
yeah me and robbie talk we got it from
the same deal really
no friends and family discount takes his
referral
yeah he takes it 500 for the referrals
he takes he gets his service at where i
got mine oh nice yeah no big deal
shout out to uh queen's key or whatever
your [ __ ]
[ __ ] kia wouldn't want to be
[Music]
the guy who doesn't have a license do
you know what i wish we still had though
because i would buy one of these
today god bless you sir i wish i felt
that on my arm i
because i sneezed am i not human
oh my god i'm not sure are you my
nephew's dead
death new trick where he because we were
laughing he was sticking his finger all
the way up his nose and then it was
making him sneeze
oh i do that all the time 12 times
it's great dude it's like orgasmic i
didn't yeah i mean i but i feel like at
15 months you should
yeah you shouldn't be [ __ ] ill yeah
this feels great
flying too close to the sun at 14 months
um no i wish we still had those cars
with the seats that faced
outward remember that like the station
wagon yeah those were deadly
probably i mean deadly not safe but how
fun
right oh that was the batman fingers all
the truckers
yeah or like just wave at somebody and
then that person just behind you is just
like i have to change lane and that big
door
opened out that thing was huge nice yeah
i think i'll take a [ __ ] finger off
yeah yeah no no cars were definitely a
bit rough
dude i remember being in a station where
that's like the station wagon the wood
the woody the [ __ ] wood panel station
wagon my buddies matt's
family had one and in the summer in like
august dude it had to be
no ac in that [ __ ] it had to be 400
degrees yeah
the seat belts are burning your legs and
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah it was a fight
they didn't know about that [ __ ] back
then i remember like legit being in like
a car with the windows rolled up for
like
a couple hours yeah on multiple
occasions well that's where the stickers
were
you know did you put like stickers on
your car window
no okay really yeah like kid stickers on
the inside
yeah you know when you're little you
just like put stickers all over there
yeah we weren't allowed to do that [ __ ]
no stickers no bumper stickers none of
that stuff with the foley's you know
what i always wanted
to do i wanted one of those cars where
the you had to put a code in to get in
oh my god my montego had that zero zero
two six zero yeah
i always thought that felt like luxury
oh you would lock your keys in there on
i don't need my keys in the car
yeah i thought the same thing about the
on the garage door having
flipping the thing up and punching in
the code you don't have that no no we
got it
we had a clicker that opened it up oh
yeah that you kept in the car yeah
didn't work at the time i loved all
things like that i remember when i was
growing up my dad sold
golf clubs uh like like knock-off golf
clubs of something
he sounds like a real garyvee we got
going on over here yeah he's old
one golf golf club yeah but he traded
one time he used to trade it for things
like we had a black box we had all
pay-per-view movies for free
like because he traded golf clubs for
for one of those backgrounds but
because of the golf we had a 800 number
it was like one eight hundred
something shitty clubs yeah something
like that so i could always call for
free on a pay phone and i would just but
i'd be out with my friends i'd be like
watch this no quarters and i would just
like do it and people were like we don't
care i'd call home so much just because
i had a free number
i loved little codes like that i loved
[ __ ] like that
yeah no that's pretty tragic because
they weren't even the real version of
the clubs they were knock-off
clubs he called it gorilla golf i don't
know sounds like it was an illegal
operation
yeah yeah i mean she was trading it for
free pay-per-view yeah
for illegal black boxes training for
free cable
yeah trading not even greasing the guys
one thing yeah yeah but we had all the
pay-per-view channels and they had like
fights and adam and eve
oh yeah oh yeah remember it well those
were fun
ruined my childhood
trying to get my gi joe on that's even
though you got a [ __ ] stinger in your
pants i
couldn't look away no childhood over
um this one's from sideshow bub when was
the last time you ate at a golden corral
i've never been i don't think i actually
yeah i don't think i have either never
been no golden corral yeah i've been
to plenty of off-brand buffets
you know what i mean yeah yellow shed
[Laughter]
over there at the purple barn
um but i told you there's an there's an
infamous story about the foleys
we went on we went on vacation to see my
aunt and uncle
they lived in lake tahoe california up
near around there
um and we had one day of the trip we
were there for two weeks
one day of the trip like 15 of us
loaded up into like three different cars
and we followed each other down to reno
nevada oh
specifically to go to this one buffet at
the golden nugget that makes sense
that's all we did we drove it was like
four hours we drove for dinner and then
drove back that's about all there is to
doing reno was a buffet yeah and i drove
down in the back of a pickup truck that
had a cabin over top
no seats just like a regular pickup yeah
so you weren't crossing the state law
you know [ __ ] the border or something
that's [ __ ]
yeah that might be the most trashy thing
in the [ __ ] that i think we've ever
heard favorite vacation of all time
and the [ __ ] let me tell you
something the buffet was nothing to
shake a stick at
they give you a piece of fish
unbelievable
wait fish is your buffet choice it's one
of them i get everything
that's a good point that's gross
everything that's gross
yes fish fish at the buffet there's so
many
nice pieces of salmon got the prime rib
carving station they've got
going to the prime rib carving station
there's multiple layers to this
that's something you have at the end you
have a nice piece of prime rib but you
can start with
take one with you start with a fish sure
salad
we do it all start with a salad ranch
dressing black olives cheddar cheese
i was about to say shredded cheddar
cheese oh yeah cheddar cheese and black
olives were
like salad buffet salads staples
good night good night is that you've
said that before
croutons is it just because that's the
way
um who was the youngest girl in the
cosby show
anybody remember he should not pull him
no but her character's name
remember her friend rudy rudy ruby was
the daughter but do you remember rudy's
friend
the loudmouth kid that lived next door
the guy yeah he was great
yeah i came here what his name was he
used to call them crowdins instead of
croutons
so i always called him crowns now we'll
stop that you asked
heard about that on good times yeah
jesus christ all right we gotta wrap it
up
listen casey we love you love you guys
what do you get coming up you want the
folks to know about
uh well i got my shady [ __ ] podcast it's
coming out
every friday and uh i have a special
that i'm filming i think sometime in
september called inconceivable
all about trying to have a baby and all
that good stuff but uh that'll be coming
out soon
and uh yeah i think about mohegan's son
sometime in august i don't know
very nice i gotta eat i got nothing
really great you're one of our favorites
you're one of the squad favorites thank
you for coming back thank you for
sharing everything about the wedding
we're very excited i'm so excited what a
fun episode kippy what do you got for
him uh
guys as always great where you subscribe
on itunes full video available on
youtube
uh patreon.com and then the [ __ ] live
shows the link will be in uh the
description of the episode they're a
[ __ ] good time
don't miss out on the [ __ ] live shows
i'm telling you they're [ __ ] haters
that's it gang we'll see you next week
t-bone love you buddy
peace